let me pop this story we got some
timcast.com I'm not here for politics
put a judge press secretary Dodges
reporters questions in East Palestine
Ohio the people here have been quite
tight-knit about when we can ask
questions I also want to shout out this
really cool image that I'm pretty sure
was like AI generated of a reporter
chasing bootage who for some reason is
on vacation but I I like the picture
anyway Turning Point reporter Kailyn D
Almeida confronted Buddha judge during
his Thursday visit to Ohio the Ohio
community regarding his response to to
the disaster earlier this month the
American people doesn't seem to be very
confident in your ability to do your job
will you be resigning anytime soon I'm
not here for politics he said I'm here
to make sure the community can get what
they need now I'll say this Savannah
Hernandez also confronted Buddha judge
her question was hitting the nail on the
head with the hammer she said why did it
take three weeks for you to get here
why did you only come after Trump
already came and will you apologize to
people who live here those are three
questions that everyone's been asking
everyone's been talking about and even
the people who live there have been
saying where's the bite Administration
where's Booty judge this is something he
can literally answer why weren't you
here just simple question I think that
was fantastic a fantastic question the
are you going to quit question it's kind
of like hey like you know he can't
answer that and that's the one he
actually sticks around for with Savannah
he just runs away take a look at this
apologize to the residents of this city
foreign
Secretary of the secretary of the
Department of Transportation don't you
think you should be able to ask
questions from the American public that
absolutely I would like to do it without
the camera on oh what a swarming piece
of garbage turn the camera off so I can
say nasty things to you so I see I we
over and over and over again this is
what we're getting from the bite
Administration dude just own it have
some humility and try and win back some
support Buddha judge should have should
have uh like he can just say you know we
probably should have got here sooner we
tried as hard as we could I I think I
I'll have to apologize for not being
here as soon as I can I know but trust
me I'm here for you now just say
something like that instead it's I was
here he says we have been here as an
Administration since a few hours after
the accident oh okay yeah in in because
it's a disaster for them politically and
only because Trump shows up do they
respond in any way so then I see a video
of Donald Trump ordering Burgers I get a
warm fuzzy feeling and I'm like man
there are people right now who hate
Trump who want DeSantis who are tweeting
that Trump is just doing this for a
photo op he's politicizing it all the
big Trump supporters are gloating and
accusing DeSantis blah blah blah and I'm
just like
I don't care dude the Trump people over
here that has people over here I'm just
gonna I'm gonna tell all of you as a
consistent independent moderate
individual all I care about is that the
net outcome of Donald Trump's action was
positive for the people who live there
and the net outcome for what Biden's has
been doing has been neglect and maybe a
slight net positive I'm not going to
just come out and be like would you evil
I mean he's there so something is
getting done fine but it's only in
response to what Trump was already
starting have having done or it seems
like it only was I don't know Trump's
the only presidential candidate to
actually go there the fact that Nikki
Haley Vivek Rama Swami not to be fair if
they literally just announced the other
day so I don't know if he has a plan but
uh Nikki Haley she's been running I mean
is she's not going to come down and
visit they she Benny Johnson gave 20
grand to these people like I keep
mentioning him because it's like he's
just some guy in the internet and he did
more than anybody else save Trump now
now they're showing up look you can rag
on Trump all you want sorry
I hope I really do hope Trump's sitting
behind the scenes going like if I show
up and help all of these suffering
people then they'll believe in me
I'm like oh no we're being tricked into
the voting for the guy who thinks he has
to help the American people to actually
get elected
yeah okay I'll take it I think the fact
that Pete butterjay said
um
I'm not here for politics yeah right I
think that he was absolutely there for
politics but I think that that was
almost a slight to Donald Trump to say
oh because that's that's their narrative
is that Trump's there for politics but
he's like I'm not there for politics
like I'm not going to be political about
this like you are literally here for
like this is your job your job is being
here for politics like you're not here
out of the goodness of your heart right
now
you're here for politics you're here
because you have to be because Donald
Trump called you out like I'm stupid and
that may be true of Donald Trump of
course but like here's a guy who's like
hey I know how to get elected I'll help
people and then booty judge goes uh fine
okay I guess I'll go this is the most
beautiful thing about the bite
Administration yeah Kareem Jean-Pierre
you got Buddha you got Biden who's
barely functioning all of them have this
deep-seated disdain for the American
people that there's just this thin
veneer that washes away when there's any
sort of controversy you see Korean
Jean-Pierre she kicks out that African
reporter because he's asking like one
semi-hard question
um Buddha judge who can't even you know
bring himself to pretend to care about
the people of East Palestine it did like
he's hilarious he's been absent over
like every major transportation disaster
yes and it's all falling apart under his
watch
I just I want to let the reality for
people Buddha judge is a small town
mayor he runs for president for some
reason because they got nobody and then
because Langley told him to and they
said they wanted all the moderates to
drop out and then endorse Joe Biden so
that Joe Biden would get boosted in the
primary and they probably said okay
we'll give you a cushy do nothing job
like Transportation secretary and he's
like sure we're gonna do nothing just
we'll put your name exactly dude and so
now it's like now he's showing up I bet
he's on the phone like why am I doing
this I'm gonna quit like you can't quit
you can't you agree to this well the
irony of the whole thing and you can
find this clip when Pete butterjay
accepted the position as Transportation
secretary
the whole interview they're like well
why did you take this he goes well
brace yourself I've always loved trains
that's right I've always loved trains he
looks like a guy that likes trains yeah
and that was that was it yeah I like to
ride on them I like to watch them this
whole thing was about how much you love
trains and then this happens with a
train that I just I love it because he
looks like a guy that just wanted
paternity leave for like the rest of his
life and he didn't get it and they're
like oh there's actually catastrophes
that happen if I'm utterly terrible at
this position and he is he's horrible he
is he's putting to the test like how bad
you can be at your job before someone
fires you fauci has been trying for 40
years desperately for anyone within the
American political establishment to
finally conclude oh my God you're
responsible for so Much Death and
destruction we gotta get rid of you nope
say it put a judge comes in and he's
like look in a year I can have the
airlines in complete disarray I can have
it to the point where you're not sure if
you're going to get to your destination
on any flight we've had two close calls
with Airlines in like a month where
there was one FedEx cargo plane coming
in and almost hit I think it was a
Southwest plane that was another close
encounter Buddha judge I would say he's
not even asleep on the job so here's
here let's pull up this article there's
the supply chain issues we have we we
are using uh AI to generate some of
these images and I'm assuming they typed
in the headline or they typed in
reporter asks Buddha judge question
about train derailment and so you can
see in the background there's a train a
reporter but Buddha judge is wearing a
Hawaiian shirt and holding some kind of
fruity beverage and I'm assuming it's
because when the AI was scouring the
internet for information about Buddha
judge it was like okay his the Buddha
judge is the guy on vacation who doesn't
work exactly there's probably tons of
Articles saying he's on vacation and so
the AI made that image oh my gosh didn't
he just say something I I'm totally
quoting this off the top right now but I
feel like when he was asked by a
reporter he said something like that he
on the lines of I'm not working right
now or the way that he said it though
sounded like he was on some kind of
leave
um I can't remember it if somebody finds
it I also uh would like to point out
that his lay isn't connected or on his
neck it appears and it looks like he's
not using his thumb to hold his drink
he's holding it like this oh my God he's
holding his drink like that hey I get it
together I guess I guess I guess you can
dream I guess you can hold your drink
like that but that's AI for you I just I
just love that when I saw that I asked
The Newsroom I was like what is this
like why is he wearing a Hawaiian shirt
and I'm like oh I bet the AI just as a
general search and when they search for
Buddha judge his yeah what are those
things called where you have like a
bubble of words and the most common
words are bigger than the other words I
know what it is no I'm not sure I don't
have a word map but I'm sure when you
when you have booty judge next time it's
like vacation no network sleeping
vacation and that's probably why yeah
that's why the AI is like if they're
gonna make a picture of him they find
his face and then put him in a Hawaiian
shirt with a with a fruity beverage I
love I love that this guy had such high
hopes to be president of the United
States and now it's just like him and
Kamala that's the best part of the bite
administration because now everybody
that's involved with him is just the
laughing stock they're such embarrassing
human beings this is how we feel but I
feel like the left might be priming him
to run for president
priming my flight to leave the country I
think it's I think it's going to be
either him or Gavin news Gavin
newstrom
whatever yeah that was that's what I
meant
um yeah so it's going to be either
either him or Gavin it depends I know
they want to put Gavin up against
DeSantis
because of their personalities and just
and Gavin's always coming after Ron
DeSantis about everything and remember
that whole the Spiel that he did about
how California is the land of the free
remember that the commercial yeah I did
a commercial like a month ago as a
transplant from California to Florida
during the covet hysteria I can't tell
you how horrific that would be to have
put the potential even of Gavin effing
Newsom as the president United States it
is the most horrifying thought to
someone like me I can't even describe it
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time